but can we bring up one topic real quick
what about the new stimulus deal i
assume you're not for anything
are you for anything where are we at
with this new stimulus plan
this remake heroes act part two the
heels act where we at with that again
you you have an intractable problem
because
a few months ago you had 26 30 million
americans collecting unemployment
insurance you got the same thing now
it is not productive to continually just
throw money at people
so no more stimulus that's the agreement
well we're done but the problem is
because of what has not been done in
terms of
making productive investments as a
government
is you're going to have a homeless
crisis overnight
look what's going on in l.a i mean i
have a homeless crisis overnight but
when you think of all the people who
cannot afford to pay their bills right
now
so what do you do if if people can't pay
their bills there's covet going on
they're homeless you have to do
something about the problem you can't
just be like yo
you're too small to fail by the way this
is the formula if you want to go into
socialism
this is the formula keep giving free
money
and then have a guy stop giving free
money then
he goes from being robin hood to being
the worst most hated man on earth
worldwide that's what happens to the guy
that's what's about to happen to him if
he doesn't sign the next stimulus
oh talk about a story they're gonna show
homelessness and they're gonna it's
called the hegelian dialectic which
means
create a problem but don't do it create
a problem
okay then blame somebody for it
then the person that created a problem
come out and say i'm here to save you
yeah that's what's happening right now
create a problem homelessness
find somebody to point a finger and
blame that which is trump and then come
back and say
that's why you need us if we were here
you wouldn't have been homeless
arsonist and firefighter been amazing it
would have been so good for you
we are your heroes oh my gosh newsom we
love you so much and then boom all this
other stuff happens
it's a very simple formula it's a very
uh uh formula that's been around for a
long long time that's been used today
so do you think mnuchin actually wants
to cut a deal
oh yeah i do you think he does look
there's something else going on here so
what's going on
it's it's a little bit wonky but what we
call quantitative easing what people
think of as
money printing requires a product
jay powell has to have something to buy
in order to keep the stock market
levitated
he needs treasury issuance he needs
fresh debt created
so that he can buy it up and grow the
fed's balance sheet which transmissions
itself
back recycles itself back into the stock
market
and that's why as the feds as the growth
of the fed's balance sheet has been
tapering off in recent weeks
we've seen a little bit of wobbliness in
the markets the markets have gone to the
moon the last 72 hours
on the hopes of this stimulus because
jay pal is going to have more product to
buy if he's got 2 trillion more dollars
of treasuries out there
then the fed's balance sheet can go from
7 trillion to 9 trillion
and he'll buy it all and that trump
knows and if you want to know why pelosi
doesn't want
to do the stimulus and why she's pushing
back as much as she is
it's because she knows that the one
thing that can
that that the best thing to get them
re-elected is that stocks are at
all-time highs on november the third if
they do the stimulus tax will be at an
all-time high